today of disruptions and drama at
Toronto City Hall it is still playing
out as we speak Council taking up the
2023 budget today but proceedings were
interrupted by protesters all of this
playing out for the backdrop of the
question of what will John Tory do he
said he will resign will he when will he
Matthew Bingley is live at City Hall and
Matt this continues to go on tonight
Allen needs not uncommon to see budget
meetings take on a very prickly tone
this one however was tumultuous and at
times bizarre and that was before we
even got into the substance of the
budget itself
facing a crisis of leadership Toronto's
mayor forged on with his budget
okay we have accommodated you with the
seat and you're still refusing and you
continue to disrupt Council so I'm gonna
have to ask you to leave
but disruption in the circumstances
after disruption prevented any
progresses protesters decried spending
increases to the police and not enough
they say on Social Services because
they're going to pass this travesty of a
budget we just are left to let them know
how much opposition there is for it and
also who that opposition is coming from
after the meeting was closed off to the
public city hoping to encourage
donations and Crosses an embattled mayor
continued to face outbursts said every
attempt to speak and just as the budget
process was finally getting underway
another protest broke up the meeting
until the afternoon
councilor Brad Bradford an ally of the
mayor who's also being considered as a
potential successor it's a little hot uh
you know I think we can all acknowledge
it's a little hot says the halting
nature of the meeting isn't helpful
start stops people want us to get on
with City business get this budget
passed protect those front line services
build the housing keep our communities
safe that's what this document in this
process is all about Bradford isn't
alone in his hopes the mayor will
rescind his resignation the mayor should
take a leave of absence and for a couple
months spend some time with his family
and then come back with a clear head and
make a decision
it's it will be a disaster if he resigns
Tori's astonished rival on Council
concedes the decision to stay or go is
up to Tori alone the mayor will have to
decide legally the mayor will have to
decide what he is going to do and
torontonians are going to have to decide
whether or not they support him on that
my job and the majority of my
colleague's job is to show up today and
make sure that we get a good budget pass
because it took so long for this meeting
even to begin we're now on to the
operating budget where questions are
being asked and of course that is all
before potential amendments are made and
if they are that will happen well into
the evening it looks like there's a bit
of a break happening at the moment and
this is all of course after we go
through the process of potential mayoral
vetoes which could drag this entire
budget process on even longer Alan still
so many unresolved questions here thanks
Matt now that new strong mayor law as it
applies to the budget process could help
us give some give us some insight into
when Tori might actually step down
because under the rules it could be
almost a month though it likely will
play out faster today was set as a
special council meeting to consider the
document amendments can be proposed if
those amendments passed or is 10 days to
veto changes he could do that sooner if
there's a veto by the mayor council that
has 15 days to override write it but
that period could also be shortened
either by the mayor or by counselors and
a reminder for the mayor's veto to be
overturned it needs the support of
two-thirds of council members now
politicians of all Stripes continue to
weigh in on whether or not Tori should
follow through with his plans to resign
Brittany Rosen following that part of
the story for us Brit
should he stay or should he go that is
the ultimate question Alan and as you
mentioned politicians from all levels of
government aren't hesitating to weigh in
from Doug Ford to Christian Freeland it
seems like everyone is tossing their
opinion in the Hat on whether Tori
should reconsider resigning but
Christian Freeland is clarifying some of
her comments on the matter tonight
and let me just be very clear that story
is entirely untrue
it is entirely inaccurate Canada's
Deputy Prime Minister speaking in her
own words on Parliament Hill today
saying a report published by city news
Tuesday urging the mayor to reverse his
resignation plans was false mayor Tori
admitted
to making a serious mistake
and to a serious error in judgment
he took responsibility
for that mistake he apologized for that
mistake and he took responsibility by
resigning
that was the right thing to do
and that was the necessary thing to do
given the circumstances that's the
appropriate thing to do and and at this
point I expect him to carry through on
what he announced while Freeland and
Baker say the mayor should follow
through following his bombshell
announcement about his affair with a 31
year old who used to be a member of his
staff others in the country's highest
political chamber hold a different view
it's a very personal decision but John I
have a lot of respect John I saw him at
the funeral yesterday and I said
whatever you decide I support the
premier says it's not time for change
and that the city needs strong
leadership it's not time to change
everything's going tickety-boo in
Toronto working well with the federal
and provincial government and what
happens in their private life is
strictly up to the mayor and their
family while it's unclear what decision
the mayor will ultimately make there's
been a lot of talk about who could end
up competing for the job are you
considering it all a run from there oh
that's a new one
yes really
now Tori expressed that he plans to stay
on until the budget is finalized and
those strong mayor powers are supposed
to help him do that and push that budget
through and as Matt mentioned those
deliberations are still taking place as
we speak Alan as for the public though
torontonians seem pretty split on the
matter according to a recent survey 45
percent saying he should reconsider
resigning and 43 percent say that he
should follow through with it